right Wow a tuned banjo sings out
signifying the start of the corridor
podcast once again welcome back and as
promised today we have a very special
episode with myself with Jan mystery man
Losada and of course with nico
goldilocks behringer what that's my
nickname I mean currently thanks guys
with no hair yeah guys you're talking
about conspiracy theories today now that
my hairdos that's why we brought in Jan
our our in-house official conspiracy
theory Orion doesn't a buff I'd like to
say yeah sure I I spend a lot of time
thinking about what could be what is
happening what could these is the
ultimate question so I mean with that
said what do you guys have any popular
[Laughter]
[Music]
saying like I personally I enjoy the
idea of a conspiracy it's a fun
imagination exercise I put very little
stock if not well the occasional
conspiracy turns out to be true but for
the vast majority of them it is wishful
thinking to think that human beings are
as in control of entropy and chaos as
one would want to think so
so like as a reptilian they're just just
you're trying to hold to this standard
you know the president's the president
of the US isn't involved in a giant
galactic watch organization to mess us
up no no it's fine sure conspiracy
theories or bunch of bang believe it
gobbledygook and definitely landed on
the moon which we
great great so we've got competing
opinions which is which is a perfect
setup and you know I I'd also like to
throw my two cents and on that
disclaimer nothing that is said on this
podcast I could be attributed to believe
so this is all just for fun my my the
favorite thing that I have ever heard
about conspiracy theories is from Dan
Carlin I've said this before I'll say it
again guys the reason why people come up
with conspiracy theories is because they
just can't sit with the fact that one
person or a small group of people or
something like that could have so much
effect on so many different people and
so the actions of one man like Lee
Harvey Oswald could infect or affect the
world so greatly it had to be more than
just him that's the idea and I heard the
other way whereas people can't stay with
the fact that someone didn't call the
shots when something catastrophic
happens like the coronavirus that wasn't
just mother nature and just happened
chance somebody had to have done that
sure but he has to be in control the
words not just chaos and we all might
just die for an asteroid know someone
someone's calling the shots somewhere
right it was in control and to the point
that they're micromanaging the world and
all of its interactions to just an
incalculable degree yeah yeah I mean
that I think makes you feel better about
the world around you right if you if you
feel that way at least makes you think
someone's in control right like I can at
least appreciate the the type of
thinking that oh the CIA is real evil
but they are in control of everything so
yeah I don't I don't know I could see
the the comfort you sort of get from
thinking that way there's also that
thrill you get of like I know something
that everybody else doesn't you know
when you do get to know something that
every else does and there's like woo and
then like you know this is a chance for
you to do that a little bit more but
that said it's very fun to talk about
conspiracy is best it's like more fun
than almost anything and now do you get
anything out of it outside of a sad life
no
we make your life a little bit sadder no
what what are your favourite conspiracy
theories um did you bring one to the
table loads is this off like what's the
to be honest Jen you have some really
great ones it's like one of my favorite
things is on our one wheel ride so
you've been discussing Big Foot recently
No we can get there because Bigfoot's
one of those like it's like the Loch
Ness monster which you've also been
discussing recently yeah old-fashioned
the moment cameras are invented Loch
Ness monster legs does a beard like
looking at the Loch Ness monster photo
it's clearly like three inches bigger
died within seconds you're like that's
fake I mean up until at least the 90s
there there were like credible Loch Ness
monster sightings that come on
like that's just craziness but would it
be cool if there was a dinosaur living
in Scotland there could be there could
there very well yeah and like they they
were they were around a lot longer than
we were that really deep yeah
and it's a high altitude they bring
something I forget the name yeah but
it's like it's like a mild deep that's
where you'll find some dinosaur else
whoa
Lake Baikal yeah yeah or Krakens or sub
there's something down there
there's something down there this is
like all creatures this isn't quite
conspiracy theory related but before we
get off because it's like into these
conspiracy theory trains I just want to
say our generation so you know Jake
myself Jan like we're in our 30s I think
our generation is truly the last
generation to have lived in a unmapped
world like there was just the briefest
moment and we were still like little
children like you know five to ten years
old when there's still a couple regions
of the earth that hadn't quite been
mapped yet there's still some some
mystery made enough satellites up sure
yeah
a secret dinosaur commune like you know
in the middle of Africa anyways at this
point you can see the entire world from
your web browser and there's no more
mystery anywhere now there's still like
Pinkney tribes and stuff right but we
have them completely mapped out like
yeah there's no we haven't charted
waters we haven't mapped the ocean
though I mean you are you are giving so
much trust to Google for just cuz cuz
the savage lands are out there right the
Hollow Earth in somewhere it's just they
just take that stuff out of the
satellite view
hey everyone before we begin the podcast
I just wanted to let all you true tongs
know that we created a mocap hoody much
like the mocap crewneck and we put it in
corridor digital dot store and we also
brought back the mocap crew neck and the
joggers now these are three of the most
popular items we've ever had in the
store they've all sold out right away
when we've introduced them and I'm
telling you now here in the podcast
because you guys are the closest to
everything that we do around here
now the mocap hoody we spent months and
months and months designing it is super
comfortable it's really high quality and
it has even a little hidden pocket right
in the front as well as some nice little
tousle Hardware pieces that are for your
eyes only so anyway if you're interested
head on over to corridor digital dot
store and check those out let's talk
conspiracies all right so I'm gonna step
back here and let our the star of the
show here Jam take a step jam take it
away Jam what's your favorite conspiracy
theory as of recent my I've been I've
been obsessed with a name that has
already been mentioned but don't worry
it's not the big one
see JFK a lot of conspiracy theories
around good ol John F Kennedy but did
you know his brother Bobby has some very
interesting conspiracies associated with
his death it's actually I would argue
far more interesting you have no
so we know Bobby Kennedy was the story
is he was assassinated in the kitchen of
what was it the Continental Hotel
ambassador hotel and I 68 and which is
right across from my law school oh wow
they tore it down they tore it down yeah
oh no they tore the hell out of that
that place is haunted by it like a
Kennedy you got to tear it down
that's just immediate teardown no so uh
see Jake actually knows quite a bit
about Bobby Kenny did you know anything
about do you know anything about what's
the official story good so uh uh Bobby
Kennedy had just won the the primary for
the democratic election it just won the
primaries gives a speech he's in
California uh gets off stage cameras are
still rolling they're just showing crowd
shots he goes through a kitchen pantry
where a man named scene hon Sirhan
Sirhan yes monster son that's right yeah
same exact name twice Sirhan Sirhan a
disagreement Griffith he's 5 2 and 115
pounds he's like a jockey young dude too
he walks up and according to their that
it gets very convoluted but he shoots 8
shots at Kennedy right three of them hit
him one goes through his coat and the
rest hit other witnesses all of its
recorded of dozens of witnesses and he
gets arrested for killing Bobby Kennedy
now open-and-shut case I mean dozens and
dozens and dozens and dozens of people
witnessed it there's audio recording I
mean they base it they caught him
red-handed as red-handed as he could
become now but before anything let's
look at the wound
now oh man
so Sirhan Sirhan was carrying an
eight-shot revolver it was a 22 uh
pretty small I have the name for it I'm
not the biggest gun guy so maybe you
guys will know it it's an IJ cadet
revolver its pockets like a standard 22
like simple yeah it's meant to like fit
in a pocket it's real small it could
yeah so he fires he expends all eight
rounds at Kennedy now three hit Kennedy
directly two of them stay in his body
one of them exits through I believe it's
the head shot that exits there the five
bullets hit victims and so and and of
those five bullets that hit the victims
all stayed inside the victims whose so
one of the bullets went out I believe
sorry the one through the head and the
one through the jacket both go through
the doorway but and there are two bullet
holes in the doorway but there are three
additional bullet holes in the crown
molding and one in the ceiling now LAPD
will say it was three ricochets at
point-blank range in a kitchen with it
just does not it just does not seem very
likely um and uh and the LAPD did a [ __ ]
job of containing the crime scene they
destroyed the crown molding within weeks
of photographing it as well as taking
out that piece of the ceiling ham once
again destroying it weeks later now it's
it was heavily photographed but that's
super what the hell's happenin there oh
pretty big political figure just gotten
yeah now several witnesses say he was
face to face with Kennedy a couple of
them even say he was like going for a
handshake or looked like he was trying
to do a handshake and
again Kenny he's coming offstage he's
just shaking hands he's probably uh uh
having a good time now all of the wounds
were from behind so there's a and look
when you have a bunch of people in the
same space corroborating stories start
to get a little muddy but almost no one
of the witnesses state he was coming
from behind them in the audio recording
you can actually hear a woman gasp
before he starts letting out the shot
man isn't a foot it isn't their footage
of this so there is footage of him
getting off stage and walking away but
by the time he hits the pantry he's out
of the shot it's now just a shot of a
crowd and the mics are still going in
and around Kennedy so you could still
hear what happens but you don't you you
can't see it now the audio because
someone in 2007 I forget his name did
just the mother of all crazy person I'm
gonna spend two years analyzing an audio
clip and remap basically made an HD
version where he could identify the gun
spikes the shot spikes inside of the
recording and he found 13 individual
gunshot shots being fired
now those 13 lineup with the amount of
bullet holes that were left in the crime
scene and that tape that the the that he
remastered the the living Kennedy's now
believe is proof of this very conspiracy
but I know you're thinking guys I know
what you're thinking he's involved right
yeah the other shooters beep well let's
get into it
wait hold on real quick I have the clip
here I just want a sure unfortunately I
looked it up earlier because I thought
maybe we'll play it on the podcast but
it is so hard to hear it is so hard to
listen to
yeah I mean give it a shot good job you
started here yeah all right we're
listening to this expert now evidently
they got nothing from that I got nothing
so the the HD clip you hear the pop up
up so the HD clip he actually breaks it
down and their waveforms online like he
has posted it all there's a CNN
interview with him and he identifies
where those individuals are now other
people have to tell for every side in
this whole narrative because we haven't
even got to the fun stuff yet
um but for every side in this narrative
there's a counter-argument and so it's
so hard to do armchair detective work on
a crime that happened 60 years you know
it is so incredibly difficult to be an
armchair detective now god no I swear I
hear on sex robots or whatever okay
before we get into the other shooters
can we just can we just look at a few
things here I was keeping notes
I was write down the facts okay okay so
eight shots but in his revolver but 13
it would explain the number of bullet
holes
um so I might be slightly off with right
oh my god there's more bullet holes than
there are shots
that's this yeah
yes that is the idea that there were two
shooters and that's what caused yes also
in the first and foremost you're talking
about 22 probably 22 long-rifle
regular 22 lead rounds
sure okay now those rounds those those
explanation here incoming explanation
why wait when when rounds fired and they
hit almost anything especially those
tiny rounds if they don't hit something
solid
they split okay okay so the the they
were full bullets pulled like retrieved
from the client a crime scene so it
wasn't like partial yeah wasn't partial
round okay it wasn't debris yeah it
wasn't debris none uh so wait wait so
this is documented they pulled real
extra rounds out of the crown molding
yeah from the crown molding yes okay
well there's actually some evidence to a
show unfortunately wasn't brought up in
in court but there is some evidence to
show that some of the rounds pulled out
of the wall did not match see your hands
your hands a weapon now none of that was
again all of this is hazy but yes there
is some evidence out there that that's
suspects that it was fired from two
different 22 pistol now I know what
you're thinking I know I know
who were them other shooters yeah the
other shooters it's so first at first
let's look at uh let's look at a little
guy I believe his name um he's a
security guard I believe it was either
Caesar or Shaun anyone who's a security
guard they're not Caesar Chavez no so
the security guard at the event was seen
pulling out his pistol and it was a
revolver now the security guard
gets questioned by cops later and he
says indeed he did pull it out but he
never fired it and he was a 38 how could
a 38 shoot 22 rounds right and the cops
are super they're stoked with this great
well you can modify the barrel pretty
easily but then he just for some [ __ ]
reason
uh-uh-uh-uh-uh at state oh but I do have
a 22 pistol at home so the cops go by to
take a look at it indeed it's a 22
pistol indeed he said he had shot it uh
pretty recently and indeed it had been
fired recently but there wasn't much
other evidence tying him to it and again
he said he didn't have it there now
seven years later an investigator tries
to track down a lead still trying to get
this story
understood uh they contact him and he
goes oh no I sold that pistol long
before the the events of the the
assassination no no so once again the
guy is either just the biggest troll or
is genis silly he lets him know who he
sold it to
so the qur'an's are huh this no no no
this investigator goes and finds that
guy and that guy still has a receipt for
the pistol that was months after the
assassination so this guy is just and
there's a police report of the police
seeing the weapon in with him yeah yeah
get the lawyers they're starting to
stack up anything well is that guy the
polkadot dress this is truly where this
becomes one of my favorite conspiracies
because you you you aren't working with
a truly good conspiracy until literally
something straight out of a Tennessee
Williams play shows up right
a woman in a polkadot dress was seen by
numerous witnesses
varying points in the day leading up to
Bobby's assassination now Bobby was
killed at around 12:15 a.m. it was
midnight basically like a lot of
political events it ended yeah
after after midnight now she has seemed
throughout the day she's basically there
from sundown all the way to midnight
seen throughout the space after the
shots rang out bang bang bang bang bang
moments later the campaign manager for
Bobby Kennedy sees her running past with
two other men and she is inexplicably
saying we shot him we shot him we shot
Bobby Kennedy now nearly a dozen
witnesses over the next coming weeks
come out to say this including a police
officer who noted it the woman in the
red dress was stating we shot him we
shot him now there's a lot yeah what if
she what if she was just saying like we
as in humanity like we've done it again
guys we've messed it up again yes that's
a good humanity of it we shot him we
shot it come Theory Fox did I'm reading
up on the Wikipedia article right now
it's a something about having a woman in
the polkadot dress is this like ethereal
figure yeah that's a I mean that's what
makes it so much more interesting there
was a there was a case of corrupt cops
in Boston that would dress up in bunny
costumes or like furry costume and go
beat the hell out of a dude in holding
to get him to confess and if he
confessed well you know this guy in a
bunny suit came in and beat me up that
just sounds crazy right so it's almost
as if a big ol bad CIA was trying to
make it make you wonder what the heck's
happened and they just sprinkle in a
little a little extra sauce why would
the sea
want to assassinate Kennedy I I am NOT
here to ask why my fascinated his
brother
well whoa I didn't think about the
politics there and actually we'll get
into Bobby in a moment but I I I want to
peel back my favorite of this one I've
been I've been I've been waiting for on
the the page turn ah The Manchurian
Candidate Theory okay wait wait lately
before we move on yes so no one's
explained these extra five shots or so
no ever I mean second shooter of some
sort yeah
the the LAPD and the official record
basically denies it but if if you
collect up all the evidence you can come
to that conclusion yourself yeah look
okay maybe the bullet holes were there
before the assassination you know what I
know about the Ambassador Hotel in the
1960s a great place to go shooting the
walk in there and just bang bang bang
bang you used to just I I go to the
range
you just master you smear it and then
they built a hotel you can silly so okay
The Manchurian Candidate theory because
I do do you all know what a Manchurian
Candidate is no oh it's first of all a
couple of very good movies throughout
the ages wait it's a candidate who's
controlled by a conspirator body sure to
act on their behalf
and if you're familiar with social
programming and MKULTRA which that's oh
man a whole different rabbit hole to get
down at a whole different point in time
but there are ways of programming the
brain into - acting oh this little Jason
Bourne like you say a word and
you activate now uh The Manchurian
Candidate Theory becomes actually pretty
interesting see seen huh uh sirhan
sirhan uh was a loner he read a lot
compared to his siblings he lived at
home it seemed like a very home-based
thing um he was a Palestinian immigrant
uh uh who was raised as relatively a
good boy um but he was a literal
card-carrying rose and crucian um you do
we know what a Rosicrucian is no it is a
community of mystics who study and
practice the metaphysical laws of the
universe they all of their traditions
and practices are based inside of very
early Catholic beliefs it's welcome to
the house of the undying it's a very
weird mix of of again early Catholic
beliefs and a bunch of like weird
mystical ceremonies and rituals so he
got deep with the Rosicrucians he would
show up to rose and crucian meetings for
hours at a time
disappear at the in the middle of the
night to go hang out with these roses
and crucian of those he also did a thing
called the Rosicrucians do a thing
called the trial of the candle
you basically meditate for long periods
of time and you can learn to hypnotize
yourself through meditation and having a
an object going through a repetitious
pattern you can learn to hypnotize
yourself and what the Rosicrucians would
do is they would will themselves to
change the color of the the fire right
so they would they would have just
hypnotized themselves and then say blue
and the fire would turn blue
and they actually think that this
happened Oh
I mean sure in the way that Metta
physicist will say you know in that same
like hippy way of science were like
anything's possible man like
pretty sure if you most wrote I'm pretty
sure I'm pretty sure if you meditated
for 4 weeks months years on end
sure that and you focused entirely in a
meditative practice in a repetitious
practice on the fact that you could
change the color of a fire I'm sure by
the time you got to that moment you'd
think that the color changed - oh sure
100% 100% that doesn't mean that it
actually changed once again man what is
change
[Laughter]
[Music]
no one's right so so he he spends a
bunch of time for hours on end in his
room doing the trial of the candle he is
going to these groups meetings with
bearing members of rows and crucian
circles and he gets a gun and starts
spending time at the shooting range
practicing firing his Ambassador Hotel
yes I mean yeah it was actually really
an accident he had gone there to just
guess how long he would spend on average
at a shooting range now I'm not much of
a gun guy no Jake you just moved to a
place that's basically just one giant
shooting range but Texas is actually
shaped like an early gun yeah yeah the
whole state is model of an old gun that
they found here they spend 666 minutes
at the shooting range I didn't go
doesn't go that direction unfortunately
but uh he would spend six to eight hours
of when he would go and again people
reported in almost a trance-like state
just cut ha ha ha reload first of all
how cheap was ammo back then
you could just fit at the rage just
zoned it out just yeah cuz he wasn't a
rich guy so yeah yeah um now right after
the events um he to this day because we
still haven't been custody uh remembers
nothing has never admitted to anything
legitimately the first phone call he has
with his mom and she is begging for some
sort of reason and he says I can't I
can't remember a thing now they actually
hypnotized him six times in court
throughout the the court proceeded to
try to get some of these memories back
because sometimes a traumatic event gets
shoved into the back of that gray mess
if we have and our our skulls they
weren't able to get it out so to this
day uh and he's been lie detector tested
he's been he's talked to I mean this guy
had the the world's spotlight on him for
at least a year they tried everything to
get him to admit to it but he can't
remember a thing or he does remember and
he trained himself to overcome lie
detector tests and he remembers
everything because he totally intended
to do it oh so motive right because this
is yeah so he
I guess so there was a thing called the
Six Day War in the 60s it was an Israeli
Palestine we if we want to do a whole
different podcast on confusing like
political situations and country it's a
[ __ ] ours
will have plenty of subject to go but
yeah that'll be a whole series that'll
be a whole season so RFK for some reason
one of his political
like one of the things he was saying in
his speeches that kind of got him
elected was we're gonna send 50 jets to
Israel to help him out with this thing
right now I mean what what kind of a
political promise is that but still that
so that got in a surround stare hounds
head and just I guess banged around in
that echo chamber of can hate and uh
meditation and um they actually found
notebooks journals that he would once
again do Rosen he would go into a
meditative state and just write stuff
out totally a a serial killer hell they
imagined serial killer looking notebooks
everywhere but in there they find a
bunch of stuff against RFK he it does
seemingly become obsessed with RFK but
the UH the the the biggest part of this
theory is the the woman in the polkadot
dress a very similar Aidid woman is seen
at some of the Rosen crucian meetings
that Sirhan Sirhan was going to and
about seven years ago or eight years ago
some BBC reporter with God knows what
being again an armchair detective for a
case that's way too old he positively
IDs three CIA operatives in and around
the kitchen during the events based on
photographs and recordings of it uh he
was able to again positively put three
CIA agents in a room with all this now
you got to believe him you got to
believe a lot of things for any of this
and yeah that's unfortunately there's no
like good ending to the story cuz who
knows right no there's never a good
ending to any conspiracy theory
unfortunately not yeah but that is I
mean make your own conclusions uh uh if
you believed the LAPD then it was an
open-and-shut case but if you want to
have fun in the world
live in a cooler place a government body
using a woman in a polkadot dress and
ancient mysticism uh-uh
programmed an individual to murder who
would have been a very cool
uh uh uh um president I think Bobby
Kennedy would have been that was my
conspiracy welcome to to krf cake it's
gonna be a tough act to follow Jan I
don't think any of us have quite the
level of detail you said you dabbled but
that was a lot more than dabbling
painting you spent time researching this
extensively yeah okay oh yeah well let's
let's maintain this this Jan led
conspiracy theory dive and let's take a
turn towards those yetis Oh cynic
Northwest a good story yeah cuz we got
yetis okay we've got 9/11 we've got the
moon we've got the Rothschild family Oh
Jimmy Jake tell me about them
Rothschilds what do you know man I mean
I mean look uh nothing I have will be as
prepared as that that I did take a
little time to brush up on my yeah um
the moons always a fun one the moon so
easily debunked I am very much on the
debunk side you just got to know camera
tech right yeah and it just it's a
problem world filmmakers so to us it's
like that's that's not fake that's
definitely real it's what people are
just as a quick aside people always try
to add Kubrick to the moon landing and
they quote the opening of 2001 a Space
Odyssey going look at how realistic the
rear projection is it just looks
flawless but if you watch 2001 the rear
projection looks like garbage obviously
rear projection and you're saying the
moon was the same technique no not
not at all yeah the there's a great lake
video of with a guy debunking the moon
conspiracy so he talks about like you
know so camera technology like if you
have I'll just shoot this on a stage you
know you can shoot it on film
you can't run film for the amount of
time they broadcast that entire thing
yeah the the plates would have been I
mean yeah yeah it doesn't not to mention
being it's like you know everybody's
receiving the radio transmissions its
triangulated to the moon nine times or
something like that maybe the Russians
went there and the Russians went there
sure I didn't go to the moon they didn't
never land on the moon no really yeah I
know that Nazis did they built a base
there I have a personal anecdote about
the Rothschilds okay to me okay okay
real quick primer whatever who are the
Rothschilds okay so the Rothschilds are
what my friend Jillian conspiracy
theorists and a lot of people about the
Illuminati like - it's the it's a family
of people just like any family of people
exists on the earth you know they have a
surname and everyone points to them as
the people that control the world well
they were they were like the the
Rockefellers or the Carnegie they were
just so super wealthy and uh yeah the
phrase in America was the the JP Morgan
family this is an old phrase so forgive
me but the JP Morgan family controls the
Democrats the Rockefellers control the
Republicans and the Rothschilds control
them both that's who these guys are
basically there was a man the patriarch
of the family was a man named Mayer
Amschel Rothschild who was born in the
1700s and made a bunch of money in
banking and then he took that money and
he gave it to his five sons and he sent
them out to different capitals of Europe
during the Napoleonic Wars and they
started
making this is actually this actually
did happen they started banking
enterprises in these different capitals
of Europe but then when the Napoleon
Napoleon lost his war what they had done
was they had hedged all these all these
bets on national debt based upon this
war and they made it they made like I
don't know like a an income an
unconscionable amount of money and then
they basically did that and they
repeated that process tell today
basically where they where they've
continued to debt financed like war and
then hedge bets and basically pick
winners is the theory they're also side
note supposedly Hitler's mom I believe
was a bastard of one of these members of
his family okay which is why you know he
hates you so much because this is a
Jewish banking family and so there's a
whole conspiracy there but the reason
why I learned all this to get to the
personal story is when I moved to
California I lived with the man who I
went to Notre Dame with and his name was
well we'll just call him I gotta come up
with a fake name Marquis Jones will call
him bull Archy Jones okay and malarkey
Jones and I went to school together and
he moved out here and he was going to
law school but he had never really been
outside of his like Catholic school
bubble he went to a private Catholic
school in South Bend Indiana and then he
went to Notre Dame which is also in
South Bend he never left town really and
when he came to California he also
discovered pot at the same time and it
was the combination his entire world
his entire universe had been disrupted
that everything that he had taught had
been taught everything that he knew
everything everything he thought he does
he thought was a lie and so his his his
entire perspective was like man
and bipolar and like crazy and then he
and then because he was smoking weed all
the time and focusing on these
conspiracy theories about like the
Rothschilds but you're basically
explaining me right now but whatever
could guess he failed out of Law School
and then got into harder drugs
methamphetamines particularly and he
made friends with like a homeless man
and he used to go out and smoke with him
and and the and I I didn't walk like I
got to California and I was living with
this guy and like I just saw him like
and I was like oh my god like so
eventually he I'd left living with him
and I paid him out for the lease and I
was like look like this is too much for
me like I'm out and eventually he had to
go back to to where he came from
cuz he he didn't have any money didn't
he was like he was about to live on the
street as a meth addict and so I didn't
hear from him for years okay and all
that I remembered was his like manic
drug-induced rants about the Rothschild
family and about how there was this
whole conspiracy behind like Jewish
banking and how that led to World War
two and how and all these things and if
you know anything about the Rothschilds
mysteriously it's it's it's right next
door if not in the same camp as the
people who believe that Jews control the
world and they want to destroy everybody
it's like right next to them it's
surprising like I because I do dig into
conspiracy theories all the time and
it's unfortunate because almost always
you're like reading about a fun story a
fun story and then it just gets super
anti-semitic real quick and you're like
really right away yeah we were on a cool
journey about something that yeah
completely illogical yeah it's the same
thing in Hitler's Mein Kampf I read
read a little bit of it and there's just
like he's like okay so this happened and
this happened and then shoot and then
he's like over there you're like whoa
how did you draw that good where are you
coming from man and so anyways I didn't
hear from this guy for years and you
know eventually he owed me some money he
paid me back he got back on his feet and
I was like dude good for you you know
like I'm just glad that you're like
turning your life around and you're
you're trying to do good so then I
didn't and that was like that was like
eight years ago
maybe five years ago I don't know
there's a long time ago didn't hear from
him after after he paid me the money
that I owed him and we had we buried the
hatchet we moved on but Dad six months
ago he calls me and I'm like hey man how
are you doing malarkey and he's like
he's like hey Jake
are you are you still in Los Angeles and
I'm like yes he's like I live here now
and I was like okay are you okay you
know because when you left Los Angeles
like I you're everybody you knew that
cared about you was super concerned for
you and told you you should never ever
ever come back here and he's like yeah
no it's all good I'm actually practicing
Orthodox Judaism to become Jewish but
the thing that he used to always tell me
when we were and when it was those 2
a.m. chats was how he had to work his
way through the system to destroy it
that's what he would always tell me and
then he said he moved out here and he
called me to tell me this and I was like
malarkey and so I don't know what he
like we're in his like social
psychological understanding of himself
he got so like buried into this
conspiracy but clearly ten years later
over 10 years as 12 years later he has
not he's continued to pursue it
and I didn't I didn't dig I wasn't like
so sure are you becoming Jewish to to
actually like try to be a better person
cuz its root aful progress
thousands of years yeah yeah but I
didn't ask you for a fast pass to uh I
don't wanna ask him because he was
always a very spiteful person he was
always a very vengeful person hehe like
one time this girl didn't like him and
he like kept at her for for right god
only knows how long just and and we had
like to tell him to give it up because
it was getting and he in he's always
been like that and and I don't trust
that he has the best intentions in his
pursuit
I really does you can't yeah who can't
handle the two narrative thing like I
look I uh uh if in 20 years I am calling
you guys up after living on the streets
for a while telling you about the
Rothschilds just do just just just do me
a favor middle the DA he'd just come in
day care I I really feel like the people
have fun with conspiracies like myself
included there's a certain level belief
I mean sure all I'll give anything a
thought or two but you're able to
maintain there's a world that we all
occupy and we all have to agree to a
certain like we all have to agree to a
bedrock of reality and we all can
construct a very cool society with a
bunch of cool history and all that on
this bedrock and there's a little bit of
extra bedrock for the conspiracy stuff
the stuff that doesn't quite fit on when
you are just living on that other like
shale that metaphysical like super
dangerous it's just not it's not there's
a difference between there's a
difference between that and healthy
skepticism which is short like you know
if you don't you don't just want to like
think about where we would be with the
black lives matter movement if everyone
just went around believing what the
police said all the time
very far but that said like you know
there's a difference between that and
just believing everything they say and
then believing nothing you know when
everything's thrown you're thrown the
baby out with the bathwater right it's
just like whoa guys guys just because
the government has lied about a few
Contra Wars doesn't like honestly though
that's fact
like that that's what honey percent dude
but they're uh they're they're our
people while we're people in jail for
for like spreading misinformation about
the Contra Wars right and they turned
out to be on the right side there so
yeah again there there are things out
there that one of the things that they
used to make up about like Martin Luther
King oh yeah sure you know to try to get
him to shut up
yeah like name a figure you know name a
person like if ever you are a person of
influence who's trying to do something
that's a little bit different than what
came before you or radically different
the people who are opposed to it will do
everything they can to to stop it and
that's that's where a lot of this stuff
come from it comes from you know JFK RFK
Martin Luther King you know yeah hey
Jake your discourse beating by the way
is it amazing this whole time yeah okay
sorry guys I thought I'd turned it off
and then I hold on I wasn't running on
this laptop is it literally my discord
is off yeah
that is so weird
speakers over there is it on your phone
maybe no my phone is unmuted
let me see let me just log out I don't
I'm literally thrown out is it is it is
it my computer in the lounge it sounded
like it was coming from your computer I
thought I was hearing it too and then I
muted it and then it kept kept making
noise well well it's a conspiracy man
okay let's get resuming yes Nico yeah
okay let's see conspiracies are hard
because like they need to be things that
kind just come up in conversation like
you know as far as like cool
conspiracies go like MKULTRA has the
coolest name out of all of us oh cool
yeah just listen to it
em k I'll try yeah it's more combat
ultra you know as far as like secret
government operations going nothing
beats the Manhattan Project oh sure yeah
I will say skunkworks is in the next
coolest thing in my opinion
tell me about Jake do you know much
about skunkworks
no I have an annex yeah I got one more
when you're done okay well skunkworks
isn't so much well maybe it can be
considered considered a conspiracy
theory that turned out to be true but
basically this is what area 51 was built
for um no I mean it's built for a lot of
things but basically no its military the
house the looming alien menace
they have in case you know Will Smith
and Jeff Goldblum need to come back and
take on aliens anyways so skunkworks is
basically the government going alright
we need to come with some cool things
for our Air Force because technology is
moving forwards things like this radar
is causing problems for us because
people can now detect our airplanes so
how do we do things like have spy planes
and like get into you know enemy
airspace so there's a lot of different
solutions you can either go really high
you can go really fast or you can this
is the most secret of all of it make it
undetectable by radar okay so getting
really high was pretty straightforward I
think that's what the b-1 bomber was you
just get a little bit of that yeah you
know is may see a photo recon plane I
guess it wasn't a bomber I don't know I
said b-1 bomber it's not a b-1 bomber
but there's a photo recon plane and it
had like two tires in the center had to
land like a bike so you to like land a
plane like you're landing a bicycle and
really really high it ideally is out of
the range of missiles and all that kind
of stuff so then you also have the sr-71
blackbird which is the fastest aircraft
ever built in fact sr-71 blackbird was
built in a way so like when the plane
gets going fast you know the fiction
from the air and everything heats it up
so when it's on the ground and it's not
flying it like Mach 5 or whatever
it actually leaks fuel because the whole
plane is loose like the lame really
tightens up from the heat chain that's
me the experimenter to other things like
being able to see like a transformer
style plane within a plane like you're
flying a plane and a smaller plane drops
out of it I think about like two
decisions that altered our world for the
negative and one of those is going away
from steam based technology because you
can you can get a steam engine of I shot
a Jay Leno's Garage for like a year and
he had a couple of steam cars that could
get up to 90 Wow and they look like
things out of the damn 30s and he
just ripping down these racetracks the
fact that we steered away from if you
crash them they would explode that's why
we don't do that
but that and the fact that we didn't do
that that we didn't make transforming
planes are the two greatest mistakes
America has ever made it used to say
test piles died planes but then the
other crazy one was the F so the other
crazy one was the f-117 which basically
so they're trying to figure a dar you
know radars pretty straightforward you
shoot out a radio wave it bounces off a
surface and comes back and by measuring
that you can figure out if it's you know
you shoot it up into the air and I
getting radio waves back cool they're
bouncing off of something then so
they're like oh how do we make it so the
planes don't bounce radio waves back
towards the receiver like well let's
build a plane out of numerous flat
surfaces that like never aligned with
each other so and radar waves hit it
there's not like a unified direct
reflection they've you know they reflect
in different directions but there's not
like a unified signal and so the f-117
looks like a low-polygon airplane it's
basically like an old Star Fox like sure
you know Super Nintendo model and looks
super cool and the plane was basically
undetectable by radar basically its
radar signature was about the size of a
bird in fact when they're doing tests
you know when they've set up for the
first time they shot radar at it they
couldn't see it until a bird landed on
it they're like that's where it is which
is super cool like the crazy tech that
they're making you know so the tech
that's in the in the especially for the
time yeah yeah sure so the tech that's
in the f-117 went on to become the tech
that's in the b-2 bomber which is
undetectable by radar as well as the
f-22 Raptor and some of the other newer
jets as well no now everything has
stealth my my favorite what if slash
conspiracy theory aircraft design that
hasn't been publicly known yet is that
of the silent helicopters so helicopters
the tips of the blades tend to break the
sound barrier which is what gives you
that sound I could be wrong about that
but I believe that's you know that's
what's causing it so you get a lower
rotor
but then you also install speakers that
dude noise reduction technology so you
can inverse the sound waves and kill the
sound from the helicopter right there by
having a silent aerial weapons platform
which arguably you can just fly high
enough that people can't hear it it's
it's probably all [ __ ] by the way
cuz you know the the advantage of a
chopper is that it can just sit at a
relatively low altitude and just sit
there that something a plane can't do
planes can go way faster and choppers so
what is it just well I mean we'll see I
mean the idea that like well I mean
think about how terrifying this is you
know you're you're an insurgent you're
you're some you know there's some podunk
army you know in some third-world
country and America decides to invade
you you know all right well we're gonna
we're gonna mount some resistance here
you know I'm gonna get my my friends
together gonna grab some guns and you
know it's nighttime we're gonna do a
raid on the base or you know something
sure it's like literally imagine
stepping out your door pitch-black night
and then just a 40 millimeter shell or
something just drops on you and kills
you and you can't hear where it comes
from you can't see where it comes from
absolutely just because there's silent
helicopters you know a couple thousand
feet up with thermal and infrared vision
just literally watching your your town
it's like you are helpless sure like
that that would suck I mean in that the
drone in that what drones try we are
already doing that just a new way to uh
to enforce that peace through superior
firepower yeah yeah yeah anyways that's
that's [ __ ] me Oh
the Roswell remember the Roswell alien
thing so I actually Bill Nighy out of
all people explained what that was with
it I can't wait apparently he actually
worked with some people and had
clearance that's what he wanted that was
the story
so but the thing is it's actually super
plausible so the Soviet Union is testing
nukes right and America is trying to
figure out where are they doing at
what's going on and so America comes up
with a relatively simple and kind of
ingenious system which is let's put in
microphones on weather balloons and
we'll put microphones you know in
multiple areas and we can make sure
they're all synced up and then we'll
just you know you just time out when you
literally hear the nuke go off and then
you can triangulate where it is so
they're testing out this platform and
this gets this you know it messes up it
goes down at inclement weather and
that's what they that's the balloon
that's the UFO that goes down that they
go and they try to cover up so they
don't want the Soviet Union to learn how
they are spying on their nuclear bombs
and figure out where they're setting off
their nuclear test sites so that's why I
was still kept secret but it was it was
the I don't remember what the code name
for the project was but it was that
project of the nuclear detection
microphones on weather balloons it was
that project that crashed in the desert
near Roswell yeah that doesn't account
for the alien corpses account a little
grey men flying the weather balloons the
the the the first guy who finds it
reports that it is a material he's never
seen before right it is flexible and yet
harder than metal is that is that what
you're like it is just a special type of
blue weather balloon with like a certain
type of modern I mean what do you mean
flex a lot harder than metal so it
couldn't be broken but it had some like
give to it it's like Kevlar it was like
an air like an aerospace aluminum long
before aerospace equipment like he's
essentially describing something we have
now that didn't exist at the time a
flexible metal that again yeah yeah that
that just doesn't sound like weather
balloon to classic then again
sounds like plastic to me Oh again but
in the in the late 60s you're dealing
with the worst kinds of plastic like if
you've ever just like picked up jugs
from your grandma's house like yeah
they're there plastic was compared yeah
again I know it's hard to sort of put
yourself in the mindset and I don't have
the exact quote of what the the material
he's describing but it does sound very
odd the way he described so you're
saying these weather balloons just were
made of this super super secret
substance as well don't ask Bill Nye
next time I see you I want to close with
an example an actual factual example of
why you should have a healthy skepticism
when it comes to this kind of stuff
in 1962 the Joint Chiefs of Staff of the
Armed Forces of the United States
proposed an operation to the Kennedy
administration called Operation
Northwoods this operation has been
Declassified by the US government and
you can read the actual proposal that
the Joint Chiefs of Staff had put
together for all the top brass and I
have this and I've read through it and
so what they were trying to do was
basically create a situation where the
US was justified in invading Cuba okay
sure because Cuba was a you know a
nuclear threat and we caught from the
Cuban Missile Crisis almost ended the
world and you know yeah so tensions were
high to say the least so you know in the
interest of defending the United States
the Joint Chiefs of Staff came up with
Operation Northwoods now the heart of
Operation Northwoods I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna tell you what it is I'm just
gonna read it from this document okay
give it to us all right
hmmm this plan incorporating projects
selected from the attached suggestions
and from other sources should be
developed to focus all efforts on a
specific ultimate objective which would
provide adequate justification for US
military and venture intervention in
Cuba such a plan would enable a logical
buildup of incidents to be combined with
other seemingly unrelated events to
camouflage the ultimate object objective
and create the necessary impression of
Cuban rashness and irresponsibility on a
large scale directed at other countries
as well as the United States the plan
would also properly integrate and time
phase the course of actions to be
pursued the desired resultant from the
execution of this plan would be to place
the United States in the apparent
position of suffering defensible
grievances from a rash and irresponsible
government of Cuba and to develop an
international image of a Cuban threat to
peace in the Western Hemisphere
now the proposed actions were to go and
basically commit terrorists type actions
assassinations you know what have you
cause yeah sure yeah all all manner of
of circumstances to make it seem as if
the Cuban government was going out and
and and rashly committing grievances
against the Western world so that the US
could then be like hey do you guys see
this there's uh we should probably just
go take them out everyone good with that
okay and then go and do it we uh we were
trying to Emperor Palpatine it we are
trying to be the clone or the clown
troupe we were the same lords the whole
time yeah we were the whole time now
yeah now it's stuff like this that that
maintains my healthy skepticism is as
much as I want to believe that you know
it's like hey you know this is this is
completely like out of context here but
thinking about a situation like this
that you were dealing with with Cuba at
that time
it's like so we want to make them look
like a horrible horrible country so that
we can go and take them over it's like
maybe instead of approaching it that way
to solve the problem you could have like
maybe got another way I've talked about
like common common ground and like
things that you could do together to
establish decision as opposed to shadow
government like oh yeah yeah it's like
it's so this stuff is real this this
there are things like this going on in
the world every day and yeah I just
wanted to point that out because not not
every conspiracy is completely unfounded
and we shouldn't necessarily just take
everything at face value definitely I
don't think should ever take anything at
face value in fact critical thinking and
a good knowledge of sources is like I've
wished the taught that in school more I
mean the understanding of like you know
a first-hand source versus like a
secondary source sure and just like once
you're reading that first-hand source
that's as close to the metal as you get
like that's it everybody's drawn the
same conclusions they are from that same
so just from yeah yeah their own angle
sure yeah I wish people were a little
more into just like instead of somebody
telling you what someone said like
President Trump said this today I wish
more people would just go and read what
was said well you know what the heart of
that is to if not only is it the sound
bite problem but it's also making sure
that if you already believe something is
true you don't need to go out and like
continue to realize we are you find more
and more information that reaffirms
exactly what you think if you already
believe something is true because of
fact X Y & Z and that might all be
well-founded what you should do then if
you want a healthy perspective is then
go and look for legitimate sources that
that don't agree with that yeah because
the type of woken up though you gotta be
you gotta be at least willing to can't
just be woke you got to be woken up
laugh a little at your own ideas yeah
our challenge Simon refine them and
refine them and
when to be willing to have an argument
that doesn't get heated right be willing
to have your your it's tough to have
your ideas challenged because you
represent with your ideas so it is yeah
I
it's a rut we're in for sure I just yeah
I wish more people are willing to just
admit they're uh they're they're not as
nothing has to be so serious guys
nothing sure and also if newspaper moved
to a subscription model that can be as a
clothing statement can we all agree that
the reptilian conspiracy theory is by
far the goofiest one but it's also the
bad guys from a children's cartoon like
would you get any conspiracy theory and
they've gone to reptilians they're just
out it just goes back to I people bad I
don't see theories based on the
low-budget makeup effects the Star Trek
you can't like be bothered to like you
know it's silly human biped but I put
scales on their face because all we
could afford was a mask like that's
reptilians there's no other thought in
my life I want to be true more I want
there to be an army of lizard people
that we are all collectively animated
monsters like to me that's like that's
the most like metaphorical you know it's
like you know when you read the Bible
and starts like with Adam and Eve and
some people take that literally but a
lot of people take that as a metaphor to
me the reptilians are the metaphorical
side of conspiracy literally killed
Bobby Kennedy or the reptilians
metaphorically cube
[Laughter]
Wow I got one more thing guys real quick
this is big news on corridor digital dot
store we have mocap hoodies what yeah no
it's not a conspiracy it's not a
conspiracy and if you're a member of our
website you get 15% off and we also
brought the mocap crewneck back as well
as those joggers that remove the joggers
yes they're still here we also brought
back the portal trickshots teeth that
one has been a very very hot item today
so if you guys are interested and
supporting what we do here consider
heading out over to quarter to do that
store or heading on over to corridor
digital calm and signing yourself up
with a subscription yeah and I just got
to say that mocap hoodie is very very
nice it's probably my favorite item in
the store the joggers also go very fast
and if you buy more than like two things
from the store the subscription to the
website will pay for itself basically so
it's 15% off the store if you have a
subscription to corridor digital calm
yep and yeah there you make two orders
and pays for itself there you have it
it also looks slick yes look slick all
right well thanks for tuning in to the
podcast everybody that was that was
great obviously there's a very deep well
I feels like we just scratched the
surface on that man yeah I'd say we got
a do MK ULTRA I just got to sit down
with a book of notes and tell you all
about not just that what you get into
the government's experiments about
invisibility and teleportation is know
in the comments what you guys want to
see next thanks for listening everybody
see you guys alright